John Healy good morning to you thank you
very much for being with us and I just
wonder Ben Wallace talking to me a
little earlier ruling out effectively
sending fighter jets what are your
thoughts on that
good morning
he's right that any fighter jets to
Ukraine is a long-term plan and the most
important thing over the next weeks and
couple of months is to get Ukraine the
military support it needs to withstand
the growing Russian Onslaught and also
to be able to mount its own offensive as
the weather improves and
it's the coordinated efforts of the West
that count each country doing what it
can and so the government has our
support when it says we'll train fighter
combat Pilots
um but of course the point the fighter
planes the ukrainians really want are
the f-16s which written itself doesn't
have
um will prolonged UK support though
require a significant increase in the
defense budget in your view
well this is certainly long term and
you know since the invasion a year ago
25 other NATO Nations have already
rebooted their defense plans and their
defense budgets Britain's done neither
uh and in truth there's been a good
crisis response but avoiding government
Vision about what next and there's been
strategic inertia if you like over any
domestic and international rethink so I
think a big test of this government in
the next few weeks is the new integrated
review in the spring budget uh have the
government got the strength to make the
big decisions the long-term commitments
that are required to secure our future
and our security or are they simply too
weak and concerned with week-to-week
survival to make those big calls
so would labor commit to significantly
higher defense spending
I've always thinking of you judge
politicians on what they do not just
what they say and when labor was in
government for 13 years we maintained
the strength of the British army at over
000 full-time troops in our last year in
government we were spending 2.5 percent
of GDP the countries uh earned income on
defense and it's never been matched or
got anywhere close in the 13
conservative years since and you
interviewed Ben Wallace he said in the
Commons earlier this month that under
his watch under the last 13 He Got years
the government had hollowed out and
underfunded our Armed Forces what's
needed now is a reset particularly in
light of Ukraine and as a labor
government we would always as we have
done before spend what's required to
defend the country and keep the citizens
safe
but how would you fund how would you
fund significantly increased defense
spending
always really tough decisions
particularly when we've seen the recent
problems with the government crashing
the economy driving inflation up and
seeing exchange rates plummet so let's
put even more pressure on squeeze
defense budgets was the threats are
increasing
you can't you have to you have to make
your decisions about what's required to
defend the country in light of the
threats that you face and
that information is classified to
government you can't make that uh
detailed call in opposition which is why
we've said in year one of a new labor
government we launch our own Strategic
Defense and Security review that would
be the basis on which we'd make the
decisions for the future on spending
right um but rebuilding the UK's Armed
Forces does not seem to be one of
Labor's top priorities why
now in the country as kirstama said
yesterday one of the the first duties of
any government is to defend the country
back the Armed Forces ensure economic
stability those are the foundations on
which you can do anything else and so
those are uh will be hardwired into any
future future labor governments we set
out the labor missions on the economy
are on green growth on the Health
Service on opportunities for all uh and
on keeping neighborhoods safe on top of
that
okay uh John Healy thank you very much
indeed